nobody likes you you girl well you're a
different color than me and that's bad
oh yeah well you dress like a now hold
on a second
whoa Mr T never make fun of the way a
man dresses way man dresses is his
business
remember that whether it's overalls
chains or feather earrings however they
dress is not to be joked about I'll pity
the fool that judges another man's
clothing
versus The Fan circus better than
Dilbert for instance oh yo what's up man
how you
been oh you know cuz
keeping it straight
all right cool well
I guess I'll check you later all right
dog
see it's raining people with James Khan
Shirley Knight that's uh
what's up man
yeah man um
how Denise oh yeah Denise
anyway
I guess I'll catch you on the flip yeah
don't yeah ain't no time
no I'm in the dog I'm in there [ __ ] it
your dog
nope all right
[Music]
oh
anyway you know you gotta come real come
correct when you come in at all you know
that's easy how I roll
welcome to metal world news in fashion
if you woke up and there was a four inch
miniature human standing on your chest
would you swat them off I was really
challenged by this question I would hope
that I had engaged them in conversation
but in reality I think I ought to be
scared of them and SWAT them away which
would probably kill them
well that wraps up middle world news for
this Wednesday October noise canceling
octagon Tire I met a world peace good
night
[Music]
did I fulfill my contract Satan
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there you are Cedric
what's up dude tiswell Cedric tiswell
yeah can I ask you a question man
um why the hell are you dressed like
this
and what the hell did you do to your
bike You Wanna Hurt
I'm steampunk now
yeah I don't know what that is man
Jules Vernon
seriously think that you have cracked
man all right like like in your minds no
I ain't cracked up
I live in a clock now just
ah
umbrellas and blimps
you're wearing a top hat with a door on
it
I'm just an ill ass Lemony Snicket up in
this [ __ ] but you
what's with you what's with me I'll tell
you what I'm I'm an ill-ass normal
mother
who been waiting for his friend for an
hour and 10 minutes underneath the
goddamn Bridge we're too homeless
put chance good sir could you point me
in the direction of the nearest
apothecary
you're talking about the drugstore it's
right there on the corner what time does
it close it closes at 10 o'clock man
you've been there a million times
I'll check just to be sure make sure
it's still open I'm telling you Levi if
you put that piece of pipe up to your
eye and use it as a telescope I cannot
be your friend anymore
yep
yep still open all right I have to go
then so
you try it no no I'm not gonna try it
because it's a piece of pipe and it
doesn't have any lenses in it therefore
it's not a telescope yes but how could
you be sure
science
I'm gonna look through this piece of
pipe and if it doesn't work like a
telescope then we finally done man like
not homies anymore we're done
oh surgery why
what you think
years
that would actually work
Centric assistant
you look so ridiculous right now I look
oh
say goodbye Ratatouille what what the
[ __ ] is that
oh
I feel like crap it just came from a
trashy Indian restaurant in a strip mall
not bad food though got pretty lucky got
the hottest baddest Curry ever ate in my
life this place called nonsense Indian
joints
it's like I'm going to my brother's
wedding on Sunday and it's like I even
want to go I don't even like my brother
my brother brothers like a jerk well
like his wife she's like a [ __ ] I
stayed with him for like three weeks she
just bitched me man I put my feet on her
coffee table she was like don't get your
feet on my cup I'm like who are you
a ginger broad man like those are the
worst people on the planet so I said
that too I said that to him in the
parking lot I'm recording him a little
bit sure but he swung on me man
he swung on me can you believe that it's
like who swings in their own brother man
yeah I swung back
but that's cool you know it's like I
haven't seen him for a while but now got
this expensive wedding I have to go to
so it's crazy I got to get my uh tickets
and that's the whole situation I hate
doing that and hold on a second hey hey
pow pow
start on the downstairs bit it's a
middle of a conversation up here
thank you
sorry about that little guy here uh
working on money from the Eternal from
within
there is a guy in there
yes and hopefully I you know I can get
like two down in one evening you know
and speaking of 2001 anything if they've
got popcorn shrimp a little lobster
rolls
stop
who goes there
[Music]
is
what
you mean everything is changing what do
you
mean
no I don't I don't know what you mean
what do you mean I don't want to die
there's nothing you do the end is near
everything is changing from the Eternal
from within
[Music]
[Music]
sorry about that man of course
[Music]
nobody likes you you girl well you're a
different color than me and that's bad
oh yeah well you dress like a now hold
on a second
whoa Mr T never make fun of a way a man
dresses way man dresses is his business
remember that whether it's overalls
chains or feather earrings however they
dress is not to be joked about I pity
the fool that judges another man's
clothing
I'm sorry I judge your clothing it's
okay
[Music]
hey Scout there's a man over there who
said he'll give us candy if we get in
his van I don't know if that's a good
idea Timmy
what are you afraid of is it because you
have a stupid name like Scout hey
whoa Mr T again never make fun of a
person's name your mama gave you that
name or you made it up for business
purposes on the way it's personal
I'll pity the fool to make fun of
another man's name Mr T's a cool name
it's a cool name Mr T
[Music]
hey Scout wanna do some drugs aren't
drugs bad
I don't know
if you're afraid of drugs we could drink
a bunch of alcohol
yum that sounds good
well guess what your hair is stupid
never make fun of another person's hair
hey Mr T a person's hair is the artwork
that they present to the heavens
it's just like I've been saying
[Music]
[Music]
and for your information it's not even a
haircut it's a rare form of male pattern
baldness
your fools
for real
[Music]